هل تتصور بانه ترك الغرب لبوتين يتدخل في
سوريا بشكل الذي تدخل فيه وبقاء روسيا
فيها مع قواعد بحريه شجعوا على غزو
اوكرانيا شجع بوتين على غزو اوكرانيا
يمكن ان نقول عندما ننظر الى الوضع باعين
اليوم
لم نكن ربما متبصرين جيدا بشان اتواجد
الروسي في سوريا عندما وقعت الحرب الاهليه
في سوريا
سالنا التقدير فيما يتعلق بالوجود الروسي
او البعض في ذلك الوقت لم يريدوا ان
ينظروا الى روسيا كشريك في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط روسيا بوتين عادت بقوه الى هذه
المنطقه سواء كان في مصر او في سوريا
وبناء عليه وبطريقه ما عدم النظر الى
الواقع سامحني بالتصرف وفي هذا الوقت
بطبيعه الحال بهذا ربما من
الحسابات التي قام بها الرئيس بوتين عندما
غزا اوكرانيا بان ردود فعل الغرب لن تكون
مؤثره وهذا الى حد ما ربما شجعه على الذهب
في هذا الاتجاه لكنه ليس بسبب الرئيسي